this is a production of cornell
university
hello folks and welcome back today we're
going to be showing you how to air layer
a fig branch in order to clone a fig
tree
[Music]
in this exercise you'll need one thing
of spagna moss one knife one paint brush
one pair of clippers one piece of tin
foil hormones zip ties and a plastic bag
first we need to have a plant that
responds well to air layering not all
plants are great for air layering but
figs happen to be very easy to propagate
using this method
first we need to fully saturate our
medium
then we will need to prune the branches
above and below the area where we will
be working
i will be cutting a girdle through the
cork cambion layer through the phloem
and almost into the vascular cambium the
phloem is the plant tissue that
transports nutrients downward to the
roots
in this case the area where the phloem
has been removed will still receive
nutrients from the xylem but because we
provide a bit more moisture and moss the
branch will now put its resources into
developing roots where the cut is made
the first two cuts will be horizontal
rings around the branch
next i will make a vertical cut between
the two rings
and i'll peel the bark back between the
two rings to expose the vascular cambion
then use your blade to peel back one
additional millimeter of the vascular
campion
applying rooting hormone to the area
will accelerate the process
although some plants may not require
rooting hormone if you have some
available it's recommended for
efficiency
now we can take our plastic wrapping and
use twist ties to tie it to the lower
part of the branch
next we can start to fill the bag with
sphagnum moss making sure that the moss
is covering the entirety of the cut area
now compress the medium into a tubular
shape and use the twist ties to tie the
bag on top
finally cover the entire area with foil
in order to keep the light out
in six to eight weeks we'll come back to
see how this branch has developed
so we're back here about eight weeks
later and we're going to remove our film
material and see what sort of roots have
developed on this branch
we can see that easily after eight weeks
there has been some serious root
development on our air layer
now we can get in there cut the branch
and get ready to transplant it
as our final step here we're gonna take
our air layered branch and we're gonna
transplant it into a three gallon pot
full of lambert medium and then water
thoroughly
we hope you have enjoyed this video and
we look forward to seeing you again
sometime soon
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu